ثمه اليوم التالي بعد كل كارثه صحيح ان
اعمال الانقاذ لا تزال مستمره في جنوبي
تركيا وشمال سوريا الا ان فرص العثور على
ناجين تبدا بالتضائل شيئا فشيئا
في اليوم التالي ينتظر الضحايا الاخرون
على الركاب
[موسيقى]
ينتظرون الانتهاء من احصاء القتله والعثور
على الجثث ودفنها يقول مسؤولون اتراك ان
اكثر من 15 مليون شخص تضرروا في المناطق
التركيه بينما تقول الامم المتحده ان 11
مليون شخص تضرر من الكارثه في المناطق
السوريه المنطقه اشبه بدائره نصف قطرها
اكثر من 150 كم مركزها هو مركز الزلزال في
كهرمان مرعش تلك ارقام تقريبيه فقط
تحولت المنازل في تلك الدائره الى مهدمه
بالكامل او متصدعه غير مناسبه للسكن او
ممنوعه من الاستخدام حتى تفحص بشكل نهائي
ويقرر مصيرها بامكانيه استيعاب السكان ام
لا تتضاعف الازمه لدى اللاجئين السوريين
من الخمسه عشر مليون متضرر في المناطق
التركيه تمت اكثر من مليون وسبعمائه الف
لاجئ سوريه في هذه الحاله تبدو خيارات
الحكومه التركيه محدوده في التعامل مع
الازمه تقول الحكومه انها وفرت اكثر من 50
الف غرفه فندقيه للايواء بحساب بسيط فان
هذه الغرف لن تتجاوز طاقتها الاستيعابيه
اكثر من ربع مليون شخص ما زال الحديث عن
ارقام مهوله هنا اما ان تتدفق الخيام
والمنازل المعدنيه الجاهزه الى هذه
المقاطعات المتضرره او ان ينزح هؤلاء
الملايين الى المناطق المجاوره الاقل
تضررا
الى جانب كل ذلك تلفت منظمه الصحه
العالميه الى ازمه موازيه بدات ملامحها في
الخوف من تفاقم المخاطر الصحيه تطل بعض
الامراض الفتاكه براسها مثل الكوليرا
وامراض الجهاز التنفسي بالاضافه الى
الصدمات النفسيه العميقه ودون ماوى او ماء
او وقود او كهرباء تخشى منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان يفقد العديد من الناجنه
حياتهم
هكذا تتسع دائره الضحايا ذهب قرابه عشرين
الف شخص الى الموت حتى ساعه اعداد هذا
التقرير لكن ازمه تفاصيلها كثيره تنتظر
ملايين الاشخاص من الضحايا الاحياء في
اليوم التالي للكارثه